I was just watching my sweet videos friend,
and she's, like,
bragging about her boyfriend.
She's like, oh, my god,
I have friends coming into town,
and my boyfriend's helping me get the house already.
Like, she's like, oh, my god,
what is going on?
And then in the comments,
I see one of my other really good friends like,
is he doing it for a show,
or is this for real?
I fucking love this.
I love this energy.
Yesterday I had a friend come over to my house,
and she was, like,
gushing about her fiance,
and I was like, okay, cool.
But you're safe, right?
Like, this person honors you and respects you,
and you feel like an equal value member, right?
Like, the days of just believing your friend
that she's in a great relationship are gone.
We're checking in now, like.
But you're sure, right?
You're sure?
That's a good friend.
That's a good fucking friend.
And I'm so proud of us. I love you.